die korona politik von bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel schuld an der
cdu/csu klatsche muss man sagen nach der
historischen wahlniederlage erheben die
ost landesverbände der cdu anklage gegen
das kanzleramt der vorwurf die korona
politik von kanzlerin angela merkel sei
für das cdu-debakel in den neuen
bundesländern
mitverantwortlich gibt es in der tat
einen zusammenhang zwischen kuba und dem
wahl-debakel schauen wir mal auf die
impfquote zb in
deutschland hier sehen wie sie gleich
auf den letzten vier plätzen sachsen
traurige schlusslicht mit nicht mal 58
nur ein bisschen besser liegen thüringen
brandenburg und sachsen-anhalt dort was
was fällt hier auf natürlich alles
ostländer und jetzt schauen wir auf die
wahlergebnisse in sachsen thüringen und
sachsen-anhalt gewann die afg zahlreiche
wahlkreise in thüringen und sachsen
holte die ard das beste
zweitstimmenergebnis und das obwohl die
rechtspopulisten selbst kaum zulegen
sondern zum teil sogar stimmen verloren
aber die cdu schnürte eben völlig ab
sprechen wir jetzt mit drei
einflussreichen cdu politikern aus dem
osten über genau diese frage wie sehr
hat die korona politik der regierung der
cdu geschadet und wir begrüssen jetzt
sachsen anhalts cdu chef des ventures
der wohl doch nicht da ist gerade dann
aber thüringens cdu-fraktionschef mario
voigt und den cdu bundesabgeordnete
aussenback com philipp am tor schon
morgen übermorgen hallo ja was ist
schiefgelaufen
philipp oder ja gerne also um zu beginn
nicht glaube coruna ist nur ein
bestandteil der analyse die wir jetzt
vornehmen müssen klar ist natürlich dass
wir schon sehen müssen dass es in er
weise gelungen ist alle negativ seiten
der korona politik vom politischen
gegner dann mit angela merkel mit armin
laschet mit markus söder oft zu
assoziieren in ostdeutschland manuela
schwesig als ministerpräsident in
mecklenburg vorpommern hat das geschickt
gemacht das muss man sagen da sind viele
negativeffekte er mit der cdu nach hause
gegangen in der öffentlichen darstellung
aber wir haben auch gesehen und damit
will ich das corona thema gar nicht
wegschieben aber die wahlanalysen zeigen
uns auch die relevanz des themas hin zum
wahltag hat abgenommen andere themen wie
die sozialpolitik und anderes mehr
standen da im vordergrund und auch da
haben wir natürlich programmatische
lücken gesehen und ich glaube egal ob
bewohner oder sozialpolitik was uns in
ostdeutschland geschadet hat ist dass
wir vielleicht zu oft politische
debatten mit dem sound von berlin mitte
geführt haben und manche ländliche
regionen in ostdeutschland nicht so
erreicht haben in der ansprache wie es
vielleicht notwendig gewesen wäre er
folgt sie haben gesagt dass die cdu im
osten unter der korona politik gelitten
hat welche maßnahmen haben die bürger in
thüringen thüringen ganz besonders
getroffen
also alle bürger haben sich in dieser
pandemie wirklich umsichtig verhalten
sie haben wirklich sehr lange auch mit
den ganzen schwierigkeiten zu kämpfen
gehabt und die zustimmungswerte der
union waren immer dann hoch wo es einen
klaren kurs und eine eindeutige linie
gegeben hat wo das dann so langsam erst
einmal unklar wurde haben auch die leute
gemerkt da existiert offensichtlich kein
ausreichender plan wie es weitergehen
soll die bundesnotarkammer 7
diskussionen geführt weil da auch der
eindruck entstanden ist den bürgern wird
mich vertraut auch in ihre eigene sag
ich mal achtsamkeit wird kein vertrauen
geschenkt was jetzt vor der wahl im
besonderen noch mal
für furore gesorgt hat war das thema
lohnfortzahlung im krankheitsfall
wo ich mittelständler habe die ihre
belegschaft geschrieben haben dass sie
diesen kurs der regierung nicht mitgehen
werden ungefähr eine woche vor der wahl
das waren alles massive themen die
aufgeschlagen sind generell gilt glaube
ich für die neuen bundesländer für den
osten die bürger sind sehr sensibel wenn
ihre privatheit und in ihre grundrechte
eingegriffen wird wenn der staat quasi
ins private eingreift und wenn der
verordnung single dann noch
unübersichtlich ist dann kommt einfach
frust auf und ich glaube das haben wir
an der wahl ohne auch gespürt dass er
begründen sie mit der vergangenheit
sozusagen in der ddr wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe aber das ist eigentlich
noch kein grund dafür sich
beispielsweise nicht impfen zu lassen
wir haben gesehen die impfquote ist sehr
niedrig warum ist das im osten so anders
als im westen
ich glaube dass das einerseits auch eine
frage ist wie stark in den bundesländern
auch über das impfangebot aufgeklärt
wird das ist ein thema so gerade bei uns
in thüringen hat es da sehr lange
gebraucht das war natürlich ein
spezifisches sein gleichzeitig gibt es
natürlich eine gewisse zurückhaltung
wir sind eigentlich ein landstrich der
sehr auf impfen setzt weil in der ddr zu
ddr zeiten war es ja vielfach
verpflichtend jetzt ist es so dass man
natürlich eine bessere aufklärung
darüber braucht und ich glaube da sind
manche leute skeptisch gewesen und da
will ich keinen hehl draus machen
natürlich gab es auch verletzungs
kampagnen auch gerade von leuten aus der
afg szenerie die natürlich da auch
unfrieden gestiftet haben also insofern
darf man die kritik jetzt nicht nur nach
berlin richten sondern ist auch unsere
gemeinsame auftrag für eine höhere
impfquote zu werben also das ist schon
auch ein auftrag den wir hier zu
erfüllen an herrn tor sie kommen wie
angela merkel aus mecklenburg vorpommern
haben sie das gefühl angela merkel die
bundeskanzlerin hat das gefühl für die
ostdeutschen verloren nein das gefühl
habe ich nicht angela merkel ist nach
wie vor natürlich auch eine politikerin
die in ostdeutschland auch hohe
zustimmungswerte natürlich auch mit
manchen polarisierenden entscheidungen
der letzten jahre aber zur wahrheit
gehört natürlich auch dass sie in den
vergangenen jahren auch garant war für
sehr erfolgreiche wahlergebnisse für die
cdu in mecklenburg vorpommern dieser
faktor hat uns jetzt gefehlt das gehört
zur analyse und sie hat ja selbst im
wahlkampf auch noch einmal geholfen in
der letzten woche in stralsund aber da
war so ein bisschen so dass die bilder
eigentlich überlagert waren dann auch
eben von einer melange aus querdenkern
en.pdf den leuten und das ist das was
mario voigt anspricht auch eine gruppe
von leuten die sich mit verschwörungs
mythen gemein machen die besonders laut
sind aber die vielen besonders lauten
zeichnen nicht immer das repräsentative
bild der fähigen der wenigen reisenden
aus deutschland über die müssen wir auch
ein ganzes stück weit mehr reden und
jedenfalls wenn wir uns die
zustimmungswerte für angela merkel
anschauen dann ist es so dass sie
natürlich polarisiert aber auch an
vielen stellen auch in großen teilen aus
deutschlands weiterhin eine sehr
anerkannte und beliebte politikerin ist
und zur wahrheit gehört die cdu in
mecklenburg vorpommern konnte jetzt
nicht an die erfolge anschließen die sie
noch erzielte als sie die landesliste
der cdu mecklenburg vorpommern an was
muss passieren damit sie im osten wieder
wahlen gewinnen können ja ich glaube es
geht vor allem um die sprache die wir
finden müssen also ich muss schon sagen
der ländliche raum viele der themen die
die menschen in ostdeutschland bewegen
die mir und den anderen kandidaten aus
ostdeutschland aus dem begegnet sind die
war nicht unbedingt nur thema in den
trieren ja wir haben dann eine debatte
geführt ob jetzt in der fünften oder in
der sechsten klasse mit dem ländern
begonnen werden soll und in wahrheit war
es dann so dass sich mancher fragte wie
ist es überhaupt mit dem erhalt der
schulstandorte im ländlichen raum wie
ist es mit vertretungslehrer haben der
debatte darüber geführt dass die grünen
gerne einen kostenlosen öffentlichen
personennahverkehr wollen und in teilen
mecklenburg vorpommerns der bus nur
einmal am tag kommen dass diese
diskussion völlig entrückt wirken und
deswegen glaube ich wir müssen schon den
alten immer wieder klar gefundenen satz
dass die bundesrepublik deutschland mehr
als als berlin prenzlauer berg den
müssen wir auch in den politischen
debatten zeigen und deswegen braucht es
auch ost spezifische und spezifische
debatten für den ländlichen raum
das ist auch eine gemeinsame
verantwortung die wir auch als cdu
politiker aus deutschland dann jetzt
noch klarer war gleiche frage auch und
sie herr folgte was muss passieren damit
sie die cdu aus diesem negativen
politischen loch dort wieder herausholen
können
erstmal gilt wenn es jetzt zu einer
ampel auf bundesebene kommen sollte
bahnt sich da ja in der bevormundung
koalition der großstädter an da ist
vielfach auch themen die er zum
ländlichen raum egal ob ost oder west
relevant sind gar nicht im blick wenn
ich mir anschaue im wahlkampf hat keine
rolle gespielt was mittlerweile an der
tanksäule in deutschland passiert ich
habe in meinem ländlichen wahlkreis
vielfach familien wo mann und frau
gemeinsam arbeiten auch beide auf
jeweils ein auto angewiesen sind und
wenn dann der benzinpreis auf zwei euro
zusteuert dann merkten die das auch
tatsächlich im portemonnaie und das ist
etwas was real leuten in diesem land weh
tut genauso auch die fragestellung wie
teuer mittlerweile auch der erwerb von
eigenen immobilie geworden ist teilweise
auch durch die hohen besteuerungs lassen
das sind alles themen die sowohl in ost
wie in west auch relevant sind und wir
als cdu in den neuen bundesländern
müssen eben dafür sorge tragen dass
diese perspektive noch selbstbewusster
vorgetragen wird und das werden wir auch
reklamieren in meinem landesverband in
thüringen haben auch eine ost konferenz
gefordert wo sich die ostdeutschen
bundesländer gemeinsam zusammenschließen
um diese themen auch vorzutragen weil
natürlich gibt es eben noch unterschiede
im dreißigsten jahr der einheit wenn es
lohnunterschiede gibt im portemonnaie
oder eben bei der rentenfrage das sind
dinge die die leute tatsächlich berühren
und wo die union auch klare antworten
geben muss
[Musik]